sie pilgern an den Ort an dem diesen
Sonntag zum allerersten Mal ein
amerikanischer Präsident Predigt wie
einst vor Jahrzehnten Martin Luther King
das hier war seine Gemeinde die Ebenezer
Baptist Church
Iden ist unter Freunden hier kann er
aufatmen aber die dokumentenaffäre wiegt
schwer auf seinen Schultern also gibt er
sich demütig
wir sind vielbar wir versagen und fallen
aber wir können unser Bestes geben um
ein Leben voller Licht Hoffnung und
Liebe zu suchen und ja voller Wahrheit
aber in Wahrheit ist der Fund von
geheimen staatsdokumenten bei beiden
mehr als nur der Anschein von
Scheinheiligkeit selbst jene die dem
Präsidenten wohlgesonnen sind glauben
dass der politisch dafür schwerbüßen
wird
es ist sehr schädlich weil es seinen
Aufwärtstrend gestoppt hat ausgerechnet
als sie gehofft haben dass er
Begeisterung für eine mögliche
Wiederwahl entfachen könnte
David Görgen hat für vier Präsidenten
gearbeitet trotz seiner republikanischen
Gesinnung auch für Bill Clinton Lob
beiden die Wirtschaft wachse genau wie
seine Umfragewerte weil er politisch auf
die Tube drücke
wie bei seiner Geliebten Corvette
[Musik]
sie vermittelt ihm wie er sagt das
Gefühl vollständiger Kontrolle
aber die scheint nun futsch weil sogar
in der Garage der Corvette
Geheimpapieren
ein gefundenes Fressen nicht nur für Fox
News vertrauliche Dokumente neben ihrer
Corvette was haben sie sich dabei
gedacht
lassen Sie mich ich werde so Gott will
bald mehr sagen können übrigens meine
Corvette steht in einer verschlossenen
Garage nicht als stünde sie auf der
Straße rum
also Staatspapiere in der verschlossenen
Garage ja wie meine Corvette wie ich
früher schon mal sagte die Menschen
wissen dass ich geheime Unterlagen ernst
nehme
wirklich den ersten Dokumenten Fund den
beiden stinkfabrik in Washington gab es
schon vor der zwischenwahl im November
bekannt wurde das erst im Januar dann
tauchten immer wieder neue geheimpapiere
auf Wasser auf die Mühlen des selbst
ernannten Präsidentschaftskandidaten
Trump auch wenn sein Fall doch anders
liegt
es erweckt den Eindruck sie hätten was
zu verbergen auch wenn es gar nichts zu
verbergen gibt und dadurch bekommt
Donald Trump einmal mehr einen
Freifahrtschein das
ärgert auch den ehemaligen Vorsitzenden
der republikanischen Partei Michael
steel anders als Trump aber beiden die
Dokumente bestimmt nicht vorsätzlich
behalten
Joe Biden haben die Amerikaner niemals
als Betrüger gesehen als jemanden der
geheime Dokumente für seine persönlichen
Interessen einsackt und versteckt
mit so etwas verbinden wir ihn einfach
nicht mit rücksichtslosem
unpatriotischem und unamerikanischen
verhalten
[Musik]
deshalb sind seine Anhänger auch gern
bereit ihm die Sache mit den Dokumenten
zu verzeihen aber selbst hier unter
Freunden regen sich Zweifel ob beiden
nicht zu alt ist um noch einmal
anzutreten
nur beides beiden steht für meine
Anliegen aber wenn es jemand anders gäbe
es ist Zeit für den Wachwechsel für
jüngere Leute
er hatte seine Zeit und hat wie man sagt
das Auto auf Kurs gehalten aber jetzt
braucht es frisches Blut
er wird beiden das Leben noch schwerer
machen denn um zum Sprecher des
Repräsentantenhauses gewählt zu werden
machte sich Kevin McCarthy selbst zur
Marionette der Trappisten in seiner
Fraktion
ich danke besonders Präsident Trump
niemand sollte an seinem Einfluss
zweifeln er stand von Beginn an hinter
mir voll und ganz
die trumpisten wollen hier nun einen
politischen Feuersturm in Fesseln mit
Untersuchungsausschüssen gegen
Justizministerium und FBI von denen sie
sich verfolgt fühlen
was zur Hölle ist das außer das
Republikaner zusammensitzen und sich
ereifern zum Glück haben sich die
Demokraten bereit erklärt im Ausschuss
mitzuarbeiten damit diese schrott-show
nicht zu einem Albtraum wird für das
Land und die Partei
McCarty ist eine Geisel der radikalen
kann jederzeit von Ihnen gestürzt werden
deshalb droht jetzt ein politisches und
wirtschaftliches Chaos gegen das der
Wahl Tumult fast harmlos wird wenn die
USA diese Woche die Schulden Obergrenze
erreichen wollen die Trump Pisten die
Erhöhung der Grenze verweigern um
dramatische Kürzungen zu erzwingen ohne
Einigung wäre Amerika ein wenigen
Monaten zahlungsunfähig könnte seine
Kredite in aller Welt nicht mehr
bedienen
die sind mehr als bereit dazu weil sie
verrückt sind und dumm sie haben keine
Ahnung wie man regiert und die Frage ist
dann wie viel Schaden das an den Börsen
anrichtet nicht nur hier sondern
möglicherweise weltweit
ist
das was wirklich dringend wäre die
Demokratie zu reparieren scheitert an
der Lust zu Lähmung und Zerstörung bei
den Republikanern wollen neben Donald
Trump auch andere davon profitieren als
mögliche Präsidentschaftskandidaten bei
den Demokraten traut sich noch niemand
den Amtsinhaber beiden herauszufordern
wenn er die dokumentenaffäre nicht bald
abschütteln kann und ein
Generationswechsel immer
wahrscheinlicher denn viele zweifeln
dass er der Herausforderung wirklich
noch gewachsen ist
dem Land und auch Präsident beiden wäre
eher gedient wenn er nicht noch einmal
antrete wenn er stattdessen die Fackel
weiterreichen würde an eine neue
Generation
seine Freunde hier in Atlanta halten
weiter zu ihm aber es wird enger für Joe
Biden